big news and maths there's a new tile in
town so we've come to the town of new
tile to see what it's all about
so you know your regular floor tiles how
they you know they go over and over they
cover the entire plane with a pattern
this new tile goes infinitely but with
no repeats
happy new tile okay so an aperiodic
monotile what's this all about we need
to break that word down first of all we
need to understand what tiling is or
tessellation so let's look at I mean
probably the most simple shape that
tiles triangle when we test late
triangles it tends to be a kind of one
up one down tooth situation going on and
every single triangle tessellates even
the scalene ones and what that means is
that they fit together beautifully like
you would see on a pavement or a wall no
gaps and no overlaps so those are the
the two main rules they fit together no
gaps no overlaps so every single
triangle tessellates every single
quadrilateral test Elites so if we were
to find a kind of new tiling that had a
new property where it wasn't periodic it
would have to at least be five sides so
hang on periodic yes okay periodic the
second part of this if you can
tessellate in such a way that there is
translational symmetry so the same
section repeats over and over again
Second Color this section here I can
pick that up and move it over and it
looks exactly the same as this section
down here
okay so this is periodic because it has
translational symmetry it's got a
regular repeating pattern over and over
again you can see how you would take
even just a section of two of them
section of three of them any arbitrary
amount and you can find another patch
that looks exactly the same and you can
pick the entire tessellation up so this
is what we mean by global the entire
tessellation up move it all over and
maybe up one up two and it will look
exactly the same fit in exactly where it
was before for different shapes
presumably that repeatable bit can be
more and more complicated I imagine yeah
it can
um so I think that's called A Primitive
unit if you have an interesting
combination that you can move around
hexagons looks quite cool but you could
do it with one hexagon as well animation
guy have fun with that
mathematicians have discovered a brand
new kind of tile it looks like a
football shirt this is periodic yes this
is periodic and it's a tailing what we
are aiming for is an aperiodic tiling
and we have tons of them actually
they've existed for a long time I guess
the most famous One
you've got the Penrose darling yeah I
really didn't think this would go out of
date
but it did I I am shocked by the news
but surprised and you know I've got more
space the Penrose tiling is was the the
lowest amount of tiles that we could
have which made this a periodicity
happen it forced a periodicity to happen
so the Penrose tiling is either made of
kites and darts or a kind of wide
rhombus and a thinner rhombus on their
own they definitely tile periodically
but with the Penrose tiling it's a set
of the two of them so you need two tiles
to make it happen and there's these
they're called matching rules so
sometimes you can do it with little
notches and it forces you to tile them
in such a way that there will never be a
translational symmetry so you pick the
whole thing up you move it around it
never looks the same you might notice
that there are some bits which look like
they repeat I do love that his name is
Penrose it's got this kind of pentagonal
Rose Motif that comes up how come if you
can C repeats we're saying it's
non-repeating it's okay to have local
repeats those little bits that look the
same but if you were to pick up the
whole tessellation move it around and
try and find somewhere else it fits
you're not gonna find it so Penrose
needed to and this was an open problem
for a long time could it even be done
absolute mystery mathematicians didn't
know if there could be an aperiodic
tiling then when they found them they
needed much much much more than two I
think the first set was over 20 000
tiles and then it was a kind of one
upping between mathematicians you know
who can get it down to 11 who can get it
down to six and so you've got all of
these different Burger tiles Wang tiles
then Penrose got it down to two which he
said I believe in the podcast that he
was surprised how easy it was
um to which I say how come it took so
long to find just the one the mono tile
then so after the Penrose tiling was
there like a big race for a mono tire
was this was this the thing people were
looking for or do people sort of left
this area of research and thought two
was As Good As It Gets I think people
wanted to find it but the faith wasn't
there I certainly did not believe that
it was possible you know I'm a little
bit younger so I was not around in the
the 60s and the 70s when there was this
big tiling boom and I convinced myself
that if I had been around in the 70s all
of this amazing tiling mathematical
theme was rape for the picking and I
absolutely would have staked my claim
and found a cool tile and now I know for
a certain that's not true because here I
am in the year 2023 this incredibly
simple shape was just waiting to be
found and I did not find it I'm a
mathematician and there's just been a
new tile discovered mathematicians have
been looking for it for about 60 years
so it's called The Hat do you think it
looks like a hat
I can see it as a hat I I did actually I
asked Craig Kaplan who was part of the
team because clearly it looks like a
t-shirt I'm untucked t-shirt so I asked
him why hat instead of t-shirt and it
was just a case of ergonomics
um it's much easier to write the word
hat over and over again and if you
squint it does look like a hat I don't
think he he even saw that it was clearly
t-shirt shaped beforehand but there's
plenty of artworks of it looking like a
t-shirt so this is the solution this is
what we've posed as the solution to the
Einstein problem
um which is a pun
yep um meaning one stone we can now tile
the entire plane the infinite plane
without any translational Symmetry and
only this one stone you won't be able to
find another place that's exactly the
same and it's a result so nicely proved
it twice is it one stone I mean I just
want to say that I love it I think it's
the best
um I believe that this counts as one
stone
um when you look at the tiling so here's
a little bit of a tiling I made earlier
the purple ones you might notice they
are flipped over so I mean I could take
this this purple one out here and if I
try and put them directly on top they
don't entirely line up because they are
in fact mirror images some of them are
flipped over the tiling wouldn't work if
there weren't some flipped over I still
think it's a mono tile I believe that
we've titled the entire plane with one
shape uh there are there are some camps
where people don't want the the flipped
over tile the ratio between the flipped
over tiles to the the regular forward
the way tiles
you're not ready for this
it's the golden ratio to the power of
four to one
there's obviously a good reason for that
hidden in the math it's to do with
eigenvectors yeah
um so for every one flipped over tile
you need roughly six forward tiles but
that roughly six is actually the golden
ratio to the power of four it would have
to be irrational for any periodic hello
future alien here but only one week in
the future so just after we finished
filming this video the same team
discovered this the ultimate mono tile
it tiles a periodically but with no
cheeky Reflections it's a Twist on the
original and future future ilian will
tell you about it as soon as I can but
right now I'm gonna hand back to
pastelian to tell you about the old new
monotail
you said something about they proved it
twice because this does seem like it'll
be something that would be hard to prove
um yeah and I feel like hard to prove
but almost one of them is inevitable so
there's the standard proof which a lot
of other aperiodic titles use which
involves Super Tails and meta tiles so
it's not the first tile which is it's a
singular tile which can do aperiodic
tiling what to be very precise there are
just maybe infinitely definitely
infinitely many other tiles that have
this property let's look at one of them
at least here's a puzzle from this very
old book a farmer had a square field but
had to sell a quarter of it this quarter
is gone when he died his four Sons split
up the remainder in four equal portions
and each piece had exactly the same
shape how did they do it do you want to
have a go I'm wondering if it's going to
involve triangles
a lot of people go for that first of all
yeah but no
um so if you do the triangles you can
split it into four triangles which are
all one one root two right angle
triangles but two of them are bigger and
we want to make sure that everyone gets
the the same share here okay it's worth
having a few seconds to think about this
it's a nice puzzle
looks like a fairly old set of tiles in
New Tail
I think we'll update it okay
you found a four leaf Cloverleaf Clover
yeah it's right there you see how did
you just see that
I'm Gonna Leave This right here the way
that we're gonna do this not immediately
obvious but we're going to take this
shape that was left over it's called the
L-shaped triominal and we're going to
make a smaller version of it so I've
split it up there's a smaller version
there and then I'm gonna split it like
this and now we've got four of the same
shapes so all of the suns are happy
they've all got the same size the same
shape piece you might notice because
they're all the same shape as the larger
shape we can do that again but smaller I
could take this one here and I could
split that up put another L shape on
there and I could keep that going for as
long as I like
oh do you know what these are called
because they're a tile that replicates
themselves
they're called a reptile
okay so this has the the property that
we're looking for and this creates an
aperiodic tiling it feels like it's
repeating but it's not yeah well you
it's got the same thing where you know
you pick it up you move it around you
can't
um you can't translate it no translation
or symmetry A lot of them have this kind
of locally repeating motifs it feels
repeating you know when you think about
an aperiodic tiling you might think oh
this is gonna go into absolute chaos
there's a surprising amount of structure
involved in a periodicity because I mean
a periodicity is almost like a border
case you've got things which don't pile
at all they leave gaps they leave
overlaps things which periodically title
you know they've got a good strong
tiling squares rectangles I mean any
quadrilateral and then right on the line
between tiling periodically and not
tiling at all you have aperiodic tiles
so so it's it's a very difficult
boundary Edge case to find and so there
is a lot of structure involved in making
this happen why has this thing here even
made news what's so special about these
Einstein tile things okay so this shape
here yes it can a periodically Tail as
can many other shapes I really hope that
your animation person puts a pinwheel
tailing in they're very nice
and that's just a triangle and we've
spoken about those so these can tile
periodically I could if I want take some
L shapes and I could take another L
shape and kind of fit them together like
this and I could keep that going and
this would make a periodic tile so
what's the new thing is that this can't
you can try as hard as you want but you
will never be able to get this to
periodically tile and that's how it was
discovered so David Smith who is a
geometry hobbyist he was playing around
with these different shapes kind of came
across what what this is called the
polykite and tried to tile it in a
periodic way and couldn't and he thought
okay this must be some sort of issue
maybe I'm not looking large enough
there'll be there will be a way to tile
it periodically I just can't find it
um and so he struggled tried and tried
and tried then thought maybe it's
something to do with Hirsch numbers
don't quote me on this but I think it's
an infinite huge number I think you can
circle around infinitely but he he at
one point thought maybe it's a tile with
a very large huge number which I want to
add in because I like the little like
Pop animation sound
that goes with your huge titlings
he then passed on to Craig Kaplan and
said I've got this sheep and I'm trying
as hard as I can to make it tile
periodically and I can't and so that was
when they started looking at the
computer proofs kind of running through
Cuda computer figure out how to make
this tile periodically still no and at
that point we have to start looking at
actual mathematical proofs of this being
the solution to the Einstein problem it
is the one stone which will not tile
periodically there is a new tile that
has been invented and we're handing them
out obviously because we're a new tile
are you a fan of maths at all can you
fit them together
nice well done so the thing that's
special is that it can only be used for
that one style of thing there are lots
of things that can do aperiodic tiling
but they also do periodic yes I'm with
you this does aperiodic and that's it
it has been proved twice very very cool
and the first proof involves a situation
like this where we build up meta tiles
and super tiles and we show that they
create a structure which forces a
periodicity the second one is brand new
and um unseen before so the idea with
meta tiles and I think I will go back to
this this kind of L chair a periodicity
we've looked at them going down the way
and that's kind of a rabbit hole that
could go down and down forever I could
keep splitting each of these L shapes
into more and more L shapes it could
also go the other direction you can
start with an L shape and ask myself
where does this sit as part of a larger
L-shaped tiling so that's taking the the
L-shaped triomino and then building out
the ways so what we've done for and I
say we I was not part of this team at
all but what a humans humans are says
well I mean it's a new a new airstride
in human knowledge so what humans have
done
is take the the Hat tile and then build
it into meta tiles which look like this
the first meta tile is just that the Hat
on its own but it has a kind of triangle
that goes around it then two of the
Tails together like this there is kind
of Four Points around it that you can
join together to make it look like a
parallelogram there is another one very
similar which makes sort of a weird
Pentagon cool the F cluster P was taken
so this is this is the F and then this
one's my favorite one this involves
three together and this is the one that
includes the backwards so yes okay so
we've got right hand shirt tucked in and
then the rest are left-hand shirts
tucked in
we have just actually been building a
wall for a few days yeah and it's
basically what I've been doing so you
give me a lot of PTSD just thanks so we
have the meta tile which the h metal
tile because obviously hexagon it is a
little bit of an unusual hexagon in the
it's it's irregular so three shorter
three longer and for the substitution
rules for this one our hexagon would
then be replaced with a combination of
three more hexagons a few of the
pentagons and just one of the triangles
it'll look like this drawing skills
engage
thank you
so we're saying anytime you see this
hexagon shape replace that with this
kind of combination of three more
hexagons a few pentagons few
parallelograms and then the triangle
which remember represents just one hat
then fill it all in with Hats so finding
a substitution tiling that makes a a
periodicity you know we've had them
before but finding one that then is all
could be all filled in with the one same
tile
brand new those four meta tiles they
then create another kind of tiling
called super tiles and this process of
kind of the structure going out and out
now means that every single one of the
hats you could locate where it is by
looking at its neighbors maybe we should
do that with the L shape so in this
level where we've broken it down once
we've got tiling one two three four and
although all the tiles are the same we
can tell where they are if I were to
apply this to what would be the metatile
version of this where they're broken
down again I can have one two three four
but these are all in cluster one so I
can say okay this is tile one two for
example I could give it a kind of set of
coordinates that means I can always find
exactly where it is and that forces a
periodicity because it means each tile
it only has one place that it fits in
it's it's Unique it's supposed to be
there I can locate it and I can say this
is the title it exists exactly here and
even though I'm looking at an infinite
plane of tilings I know where I am
because I know which cluster which Super
tile which meta tile I can locate the
address of this exact tile there are no
tiles which have the same address and so
it causes this a periodicity that's
that's the one that makes more sense and
that's um a type of proof that has been
used for a periodicity before but there
is another I think individual Tiles at
something like 300. nicely done well
done and particularly good at this
there's one I actually do think it is
part of being good at maths I think it's
to do with recognizing the the patterns
so the second proof
involves a second tile
when they discovered the hat and by Thee
I mean David Smith discovered the Hat he
also discovered another tile which is
made by putting kites together called
the turtle oh yeah I'm saying that you
see it as a turtle yeah so here's the
turtle when they were first discovered
this one is made out of eight kites
joins together this one is made of ten
kites joined together so they were
treated as separate entities but they
are in fact one in the same as part of a
Continuum if you look at the angles you
know we've got right angle down here a
reflex three-quarter angle or inverted
right angle over here the angles are the
same as we work the way around the
lengths are different so if you consider
the lengths on the classic hat is a
classic now they're all either one or
root three again there's a lot of like
cheating going on but I prefer to think
of it as
I don't know
just I wish I had something
philosophical to say it's not cheating
it's making it work so
um all of the lengths are either one or
root three apart from one of them which
is two but you can think of it as two
ones joined together
so we have the hat and we have the
turtle and they are part of a Continuum
of shapes if you took all of the edge
lengths and kind of pushed them down so
that you made some of them smaller and
some of them bigger depending on which
way you go you get two boundaries so you
get a Chevron and you get
what's called a comet shape so we'll
look at the Chevron in the comet the
tile periodically and there's a middle
one as well right in the middle which
looks like a mix between a hat and a
turtle which also tiles periodically the
underlying grid for the Chevron and the
underlying grid for the comet although
they're both triangular I'm the the
ratios don't match up so the lengths
don't match and it means you can't you
can't Rectify them you can't put them
together they could never you could
never put the Chevron onto the comic
grid you couldn't put the comet on the
Chevron grid with the same area and have
them line up with the the lattice points
which is the nice bits on the grid what
that means is that all of the shapes in
between like I said a periodicity is a
boundary case all of the shapes in
between the periodic points they fall
into this no man's land of a periodicity
so does that mean like
there are lots and lots of different
shapes not that are not hats or t-shirts
that do this yep
um then why do they pick that particular
one to release to the world why is that
one getting all the fame I imagine
because you can draw it really nicely on
a grid of a dual grid of hexagons and
triangles together something very fun to
do with any pattern is to try and find
the Dual
um which is like it's evil twin if you
take the midpoint
of each of the shapes and then you join
them together you get another grid and
so in this case the Dual of the
Triangular tiling is this hexagon grid
and vice versa so the these are where
the kites come from
um the hat is made out of eight of these
if you see the kite that's created by
two Jewel grids together the hat is made
out of eight of them joined together so
that was where it came from so it was
sitting in front of our faces yeah it's
like right there yeah yeah I really
kicked myself I've been waiting to be
found in plain sight yep uh but don't
worry we've got it now you can see it
that's the
oh it's this way round one so I always
thought the reason that it would have
this aperiodic tiling was because things
were constantly rotating at like a
rational angles or something never to
repeat but it's actually quite an
orderly pattern yeah you know there's a
weird thing it is a very orderly pattern
I think that there's only six
orientations that it would be at but it
doesn't even make use of all of the
orientations that could on this grid it
just sits at six different orientations
the 60 degrees how did you feel about
the announcement
I'm first of all incredibly excited
um then then I worried a little bit
about the fact that my tattoo was now
out of date
um but overall I was really happy I
never thought that I would be alive at a
time that something so significant
happened
um in terms of maths I mean we've had
way too many once in a lifetime events
in a bad way and I thought I just
thought oh my gosh this is this is
genuinely a once in a lifetime event
um for me to be alive during aperiodic
mono tile time
um overjoyed and then immediately the
first thing that I wanted to do was turn
it into true shade tiles that was an
instant thought and then I went to
Twitter and saw someone had already done
it but luckily they're nice they do look
really good I enjoy the true Shea tile
version of the Hat
so David Smith discovered it and then
three other mathematicians and Joseph
Myers home Goodman Strauss and Craig
Kaplan proved that there's definitely
not going to be any repeats yeah do you
know what it would be called to find an
aperiodic mono tile which needs no
reflection I don't know but I can tell
from your face it's going to be a pun
it's a vampire tile
that has no reflection
check links in all the usual places for
some extra footage and proofs from this
interview with alien plus we've got an
extra interview with Craig Kaplan one of
the researchers who made these Amazing
Discoveries it's a wild ride it's
completely unlikely and should not be
take as a model for how scientific
discovery ever happens
ridiculous and yes we'll get to that
even newer tile as soon as we can
meanwhile if puzzles and patterns are
your thing maybe you're the sort of
person who could end up having a career
with today's episode sponsor Jane
straight Jane Street's a research-based
trading firm with officers all across
the globe although perhaps not in new
tile population 800 just yet
go to their website check out the join
Jane Street section for vacancies
internships and some free and fun
introductory programs for students could
be something right up your alley Jane
Street's a great place to work and they
think the sort of people who like number
five videos might also be the sort of
people who want a career in their
offices around the world
janestreet.com is the place to check
them out
sneaky matching rules that Penrose Tales
used and just hidden as an underlying
grid it was exciting to be a part of it
and I am just so grateful that that it's
causing excitement out in the world if
it causes anybody to be you know one
little bit more interested in
mathematics you know then that's
fantastic